yeah the other burger just looks more
fun sorry beast mode hunger squad we're
gonna be traveling all over Los Angeles
today and our mission today is to find
the best veggie burger in LA we're gonna
play a veggie burger telephone what
happens is we go to one restaurant we
try the veggie burger and then ask them
where they would go if they weren't
eating their own veggie burger and then
we're gonna keep going on and on and on
until we find the best one in LA for me
as a vegetarian it's pretty hard to find
a good veggie burger I don't think I've
ever actually eaten a veggie burger so
this will be interesting on the big meat
fan I don't care what's in a burger as
long as it tastes good I'm down for that
I need a few more spots to eat veggie
burgers at because most of the ladies in
Los Angeles are vegan as we all know I
am a vegetarian I am a vegetarian we are
on our way right now to Cafe Gratitude
we gotta make up a rubric here what
makes it okay first it's not too mushy
it's not real meat it can't be mushy
permanent flavor
obviously presentation I'm always
worried with the veggie burgers that I'm
not gonna have yeah I'm not gonna have a
full meal let's do it oh god I'm so
hungry and I'm stuck oh sweet Jesus all
right so the surfers stock for veggie
burgers tell us about Cafe Gratitude
we're an all organic all vegan
establishment we are just kind of a
casual fun place where you can bring
anyone from your dog to your grandma
you're gonna be having the I am magical
which is our double cheeseburger with
our black bean and mushroom and all
sorts of spices and the patties will it
make me full I don't definitely make you
full I like to refer to it as the
boyfriend burger first off this burger
looks pretty neat patties are like maybe
quarter of an inch thick I'm gonna give
it a 4 on presentation you know there's
always room for growth I like the
texture a lot ok circle salad
mine it's falling apart Stephens eating
like a child this is
some metals upgrade for me the flavors
are good though mm-hmm a sprig of
rosemary another good flavor
I'll give it a for bonus how much do you
eat I'll give one thing I do know about
this so it is it is nutritious AF look
at Colin I fit in with the kids is they
sounded like mr. long I think we are
eternally grateful to Cafe Gratitude but
it is time to move on if you weren't
gonna eat a veggie burger here where
would you go next my go-to is probably
Sun Cafe in Studio City it's my turn to
drive and I'm gonna take us to the
valley Jordans from Boston I know how
people in Boston I'm a perfect driver
vegetarians on average fart like 10
times more than meat-eaters they don't
remember that girl Stephen so Cafe
Gratitude sent us here to try your
veggie burgers but first you wanted to
tell us a little bit about the
restaurant we make all our own cheese
from scratch out of seeds and nuts
so everything's super fresh we have our
traditional one which is our raw burger
and then we also have a new one that we
just introduced which is a marinated
tempeh burger I've never had tempeh so
food consistency nice and firm whatever
it is this is a soy product and it's a
delicious one it's got kind of a meaty
flavor to it which is interesting it
some gave you an idea yeah firmness 5
fullness 5 presentation 5 flavors 5
generations
I would say it's a 4.5 whoa actually no
now in second thought it's a 5 it
definitely holds together yeah it moves
like a burger there's a lot of flavors
to work through but like all really
great flavors overall I don't bring a
date here not this one
what a date I'm legit so full right now
like I don't know how I'm gonna do
another restaurant if you weren't going
to eat a veggie burger here where would
you go to eat a veggie burger I've heard
some good things about Beachwood cafe
it's gonna be hard to top this place
seriously but it's time to go to bed
foot I don't know classic veggie diner
what we're gonna do if you want to order
baby burgers for us you have them here
yes we make our own veggie burgers here
this is what I expect a veggie burger to
look like it smells really good
I would say it's like very classic
American fare yeah this is the only
burger that was open case but open face
is better yeah keep presentation you can
wait for it to be fresh until you
actually eat it I'm gonna go for it do
you want to spread avocado man where's
the brown rice oh it's in the patio all
right mmm it's chewy I got three I like
2.5 like this is not as firm as I would
have wanted and this will fill me up
this is a full meal just like a patty of
rice I like the flavor it gives you like
a home feeling like a warm feeling it's
like the inside of a Chipotle burrito
bowl it didn't blow my mind I've got a
food baby af3 finish it yeah my favorite
burger was the raw burger at Sun cafe we
ate a lot of good burgers but that one
was off the charts good I'm glad that we
found places where I can go and also
bring a vegetarian after today I think
I'm less skeptical of veggie burgers and
I think I've added a few more pretty
choice date spots to my repertoire for
sure they're gonna have good poops
tonight we're all gonna have it really
easy peasy the fiber just like makes it
just go
newsflash
[Music]